there are concerns this morning about a
big summer surge of the coronavirus as
the highly contagious delta variant
drives the nation's infection rate
higher debates over mass mandates are
heating up as schools reopen in some
parts of the country and more
unvaccinated children are getting sick
the centers for disease control says 50
percent of adults in the united states
are now fully vaccinated the average
case count of coronavirus infections has
soared 102
over the past two weeks all of this as
thousands of bikers converge whole hog
on the tiny south dakota community of
sturgis that's in the black hills for
the annual 10-day sturgis motorcycle
rally mola lange is there with more mola
good morning
good morning dana here in south dakota
new coveted cases jumped nearly 70
percent in the week leading up to this
rally of course that comes at a time
like you mentioned when the delta
variant is quickly spreading across this
country and two when those large summer
gatherings the concerts the festivals
and this bike rally that's expected to
draw more than half a million people
into these streets in sturgis and with
it concerns of a super spreader event
if you're a biker and you cannot make it
down here
to sturgis in your lifetime you have
missed out well they say there's two
kinds of bikers they're the ones that
are already here and the ones that are
on their way that's it this is the mecca
man
mecca or not the 2021 sturgis 10 day
bike rally got underway yesterday
ceremoniously no mask mandates no proof
of vaccinations needed we're not going
to start checking papers i mean that's
not really an american white daniel
ainsley is the city manager of sturgis
population 7000. considering the
pandemic what considerations were in
mind yeah so that's one of the reasons
we're looking at an open container this
year people can drink on the streets to
avoid crowded bars does the kobe thing
worry at all no no i haven't worried
about it at all
not since day one
vaccinated not vaccinated no not
vaccinating not getting better and not
getting vaccinated
the big gatherings along with county and
state fairs comes as schools are set to
reopen
in a few places parents who are against
masks are taking a stand
yet covid cases in children are rising
more than 71 thousand reported last week
eight states have banned districts from
requiring masks in schools yesterday a
judge in arkansas ruled the ban cannot
be enforced but illinois and new jersey
became the latest states to mandate
masks for k-12 students
i have to ask why wouldn't we send our
kids to school with a mask on
louisiana's governor has good reason to
want masks the state is ranking number
one in the new delta driven covid surge
we're the number one state that's not a
distinction we want to have
and quite frankly it's not even close
the number two state
is florida in fontana california
high-tech temperature readers are
rapidly checking 2 200 students a day at
the high school where cassandra
hernandez is a senior i saw other people
getting vaccinated so i was like you
know what maybe it's a good idea
especially since we're going back to
school united airlines officials
announced yesterday vaccines are
mandatory for its employees to work
indoors or on board and in the san
francisco bay area according to a survey
just released 43 percent of companies
are mandating employees be vaccinated
well this rally provides a critical
economic boom for the state the region
as well as this town but you know there
are health considerations of course but
you know the state vaccination rate here
in south dakota is right around the
national average and there are currently
only 13 coveted hospitalizations here so
as you can imagine michelle health
officials are encouraged by those things
all right mola thank you so much